another issue I have today which is
these oils stop the oil protesters back
in the UK have started doing more and
more acts of wanton vandalism we've got
a little match up of their Antics in the
last few days
this is
we've seen them chopping milk in
supermarkets at a time of a cost of
living crisis the like which most of us
have never seen which seems an
extraordinary act for trying to get
public sympathy they've also been lying
in the middle of roads and closing big
Bridges and big tunnels and so on so I
think my overriding view of these people
is the more of this they do whatever the
merits of the calls that they're
fighting for which is climate change and
about the over excessive use of oil
around the world it's eroding by the
second with these acts of childish Petty
pathetic vandalism Am I Wrong anyone
want to defend these people well I'd
personally say that I agree that that
kind of Act is not helpful for the cause
at all it makes it look like it's all a
kind of teenage protest and a kind of
sulky teenager pouching if you like but
at the same time I think that it also
reflects deep concern about what the UK
is going to do next on this front the UK
did have a pretty sensible that are
policies one of the many things that
appeared to be happening under trust was
that some of these were being reversed
and so at the same time as saying that
this kind of act pouring milked down in
the supermarket is pretty dumb it's
equally dumb to not have some kind of
coherent government policy to switch
rapidly to renewable energy I mean these
things can both be true I mean my view
about the renewable energy of the fossil
fuels is you can't do it all in one go
and my goal we've discovered this year
that the energy situation is pretty
desperate for everyone and in the short
term we need fossil fuels just to
survive but we are going to have to try
as a planet to move to Renewables the
issue at the moment is cost and
availability right yes absolutely but I
don't think that these guys should be
part of that debate that's a serious
debate for serious people and when I
look at that picture of them throwing
paint at Van Gogh sunflowers I felt
anger internally and that's what they
wanted me to feel if you think about
their protests attacking The cenotaph
Dumping a bucket of feces over a statue
of cat Captain Tom they are not actually
as childish as you think they are
carefully designed to provoke an
emotional reaction of Fury in the
British people it's a bit like when the
vegans start the extreme vegan start
shrieking away and doing Mad things it
makes me want to go and order a Big Mac
um Vicky before we let you go I want to
talk this quickly about another story
news this week prince Andrew and Gillian
Maxwell her first interview from the
prison you obviously had an interest
here you had a big scoop about Etsy
which got suppressed
um Gilly Maxwell comes out supportive of
Andrew his friends are telling the
papers this is the last thing he needs
right now as he tries to rehabilitate
himself what do you make of it
you know I think Gillen Maxwell is very
clever and it was very clever messaging
on her part basically what she was
telegraphing in just a few sentences was
you know prince Andrew is still in my
world uh Bill Clinton she called him a
special friend you don't want to be
called my dear friend by a convicted
well no it's not good it's it's not good
for them but I think it's telling about
her State yeah of mind which speaks
again to the trial that we went through
and is there any doubts for you that
Gilley Maxwell was up to her neck and as
much as Epstein that she knew a lot of
the stuff that was going on
no I sat through the trial she she
clearly knew what was going on she was
not by any stretch the only person who
knew what was going on and and what's
really troubling and why I think she's
called out these men is that the men are
who's missing from this story okay I
Echo that because she wrote done a great
podcast on that and it really is very
unfair how the spotlight has been so
much on the woman and so well because
the man killed himself right
no I agree lots of very powerful people
they should all be held to account I
totally agree before we go final one
word answer will this trust survive till
the end of the week
probably till the end of the week but
not much longer than that
um I hope not I'm going to Echo my very
clever friend I'm going to say an
emphatic simple because I did say one
word answer no she'll be gone at the end
of the week and if not the world's gone
nuts thank you to my stellar pack this
is we have to do this again I love this